Hello Freak bitches.
Oh,
but after Lisa was on the other day and listening to Lee on that,
like he's leads never been to a strip club before,
but his little voice when he chimes and he's like,
ah,
I've never been to a strip club of authority.
It's still never been to his true calling.
No,
he's scared of him.
He said,
I want to take that guy to a sister so bad.
Why is he scared?
Uh,
I don't know.
He,
It's,
I think it's a money thing cause he says like,
Hey,
you just don't get it.
You pay the money.
Then they tried to get money on a e.
Oh
there's someone told a story recently about Jeremiah Watkins trying to,
they took him to a strip club and he freaked out and just like ran out the back.
The same kind of thing.
Like he'd,
I don't know if he's ever been to one or doesn't want to go or yeah,
he,
yeah,
he looked at the ground and walk from the front.
You've never looking up all the way to the pack after pack tour.
Yeah,
I did.
I did get a day.
It's just crazy.
I did a show with George Perez and Compton at a strip club in Compton.
And let me tell you,
man,
that was one of them.
The most eye opening like that exist.
We walk in,
there's strippers.
The stripper just came up to me and goes,
hey honey,
look at this pussy ass.
Wow.
All the babies.
You want to get it.
You want some of this written?
I'm like,
right when I walked,
Whoa,
whoa.
What'd she look like?
Uh,
like,
cause my baby Mama like,
I dunno,
like there's,
it's still baby hand sticking out of her probably
at blue baby horn.
She attractive.
No,
there was,
there was a few,
but then every time you talked to him you're like,
Oh,
if I fuck up,
I'm dead.
You know,
like she was like ghetto.
Yeah.
It was pretty crazy.
For hostile.
Yeah.
What about the clientele?
Uh,
well they,
they,
they were mostly there for us.
Like they,
George just pretty much,
we had the whole club at ourselves.
I've always all people coming to see the show.
So it was strippers too though.
And strippers to was the idea that you would get people in there for the show
and then the girls would dance for them afterwards.
Yeah.
And while we're doing the show,
they were coming and sitting on table,
hey you went to go get some,
but sex upstairs,
you know,
sex.
So I got a question for you.
Can you talk about the run rabbit run race you had that you won or yeah,
we can talk about that.
How that end.
No,
I'll let her describe it because it sounds pretty crazy what happened.
Um,
so the hundred mile race that I was doing a month before Moab add about,
I mean 12 miles roughly to the finish line.
My vision started blurring like in the periphery.
Um,
and over the course of the next couple of miles closed in until it was pure
white.
I couldn't see anything.
Um,
so I just like stumbled my way along roughly 10 miles of trails to get to the
finish line.
Pretty much.
I would say like 98% blind.
What I could see my feet like right in front of my feet,
but it was just white out.
So I was running and um,
falling everywhere.
It was probably a hilarious if people were,
but um,
I hit my head also on a rock.
One of them to your blind.
Yeah.
One of the times I fell so I had blood dripping down my face,
like stumbling along.
Totally couldn't see the trail and he still one.
Yeah.
Managed to finish and,
and hold the lead.
You're a savage.
Should give seminars on how to be a savage.
That is crazy.
So what,
what did,
what happened to your vision?
Um,
so since then there's been tons of people kind of talking about it.
Apparently it happens in,
in ultra is quite often they are thinking it's a corneal edema.
So basically like I wear contact lenses to see,
um,
and the like contact mixed with the air and the dryness and all sorts of things
cause like a kind of fluid or I'm not really sure how it works.
If you ever thought about getting lasix or something,
people who have done lasik also get this corneal edema.
So for now I'm just,
uh,
stay in,
stay in with the contacts because I've,
I've been learning how to deal with those a little bit better.
What do they look?
Do they look different?
I look a fair bit different.
So that first bullet Jamie showed was like a Brahmin bull.
Then one of those Grable's,
which is just bits of frigging every sort of bull over a lot of generations will
come in and Nyland buried with it and then sort of wrecks the herd.
And when,
when did they get released or when did they escape?
Well,
it would have been with the first Cadillac come into Australia.
So 18 hundreds and hundreds.
Yeah.
Wow.
So they've just sort of morphed and become wild animals and the wild bulls.
Very dangerous.
Yeah.
So what happened was,
Pedro,
I shot these bowling and it dropped like,
you know,
down conscious.
He fought,
it was dead,
walked up to it.
It jumped up.
Like he literally got up to it and it jumped up.
And anyway,
it ended up getting him against the tray.
Like he ran to get up a tree,
he felt it hit him and it sort of lifted him up the tree.
He climbed up the tree is the gross bit.
Then he felt something warm and his legs and looked down and his guts and
everything hanging down.
And I read his legs but he's a tough boss.
Did he?
Gavin his stomach back up and sort of hold it in place.
Then the ball actually died.
He climbed down out of the train,
ended up dawn two times I think once in the air because the royal flying doctors
come in,
grabbed him cause he's a long way out in the middle of nowhere.
And uh,
then once on the table is operating table as well.
Wow.
He survived all that and end up dying of a bloody mess,
heart attack.
So no way.
Yeah.
When uh,
it was only thing,
it was only 36 or 37.
Do you think it had anything to do with the accident that I reckon it was
related at all.
Really?
Yeah.
You would think that a guy could get past getting gored by air,
pushes guts back into them.
Like,
that guy's not going to get a heart attack.
Uh,
that's life's not fair.
Right.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Right?
But I mean,
has anybody been skeptical as anybody?
Yeah.
Everyone's skeptical.
And w w what's your response to that?
You don't know what I know,
right?
Well,
what do you know though?
I don't know.
I can't tell you some of the shit that I know and I can't tell you,
but what could it be?
That's so crazy if you,
you know,
I mean what you've said,
we'll think about what you've said.
You said that there's some ridiculous sorta propulsion system that allows you to
move through time,
that they,
they visit this planet all the time and extract resources,
right?
That there's people in the government that are trying to disseminate this
information,
but they don't know how to do it.
They don't have the right vehicle do it.
They're doing it in these sort of controlled chunks.
Think of all these things that you've said.
What could possibly be crazier than that?
Well you're asking me how do I know and no,
no,
no.
I'm asking you what do you know that could possibly be crazier than that?
Well,
that's the shit.
I can't tell you.
It's not everything's Hunky Dory.
Is it something where you worried about the fate of the human race?
I think that's part of it.
Where should I move?
If I was going to move?
It's not existential.
If your dick out of I should go to Australia.
How about,
how about I guess pick out in Australia?
I mean where's the spot?
I don't think there is one spot.
They just,
this is,
this is what I will say.
It's not existential in the sense of a,
they're,
I'm not going to come here like independence day in nuke the place.
Um,
but it,
there,
you know,
there are things to worry about but sometimes you read these books with the
writers go a little too far with that bullshit,
you know what I'm saying?
Whatever.
It's just too much.
It's like you were saying,
you ever go to people's houses and they talk and then he'd say shift for 20
minutes.
They let a lot of,
it's like by studios to the,
where I live,
go to that coffee shop from time to time,
you know what they was saying in the world,
but they,
after the Vegas shooter,
the Vegas shooter was Sunday night.
Do you know what these idiots were saying in there Monday?
But that this had to do with women's rights and abortions and they just talk
these new,
this new breed of gentiles.
They just talk.
That's all they do is talk with big words to impress you.
But then don't say shit.
Don't say shit.
Three or four big words to let you know they're smart.
And then they didn't say nothing.
And there's a lot of repeating narratives.
Oh yeah.
Every time the show,
the new show I'm gonna do,
I'm buying one of those little tape recorders,
putting up Mondays,
six fucking morons every day.
Then at night I'm going to do a show about what they discussed because this is
60% of America with these fucking people are talking about this is the idiots.
The shit that comes out of that mouth is amazing.
And you sit there and go,
no one to fucking isis wants to shoot us.
Listen to these fucking dummies.
Listen to what's coming out of their mouth.
Women's rights.
That's what they talking about that.
Well,
what was their argument there?
They were saying that the guy,
they all get that argument.
Is everybody trying to be smarter than everybody?
It's just six people trying out with each other.
It's like when you go to those fucking dinner party parties you talk about,
and by the time they served the salad,
you want to put a gun in your fucking mouth.
Why am I even fucking here with these people?
I could have stopped at Burger King and had a better fucking time.
That's why I don't go to those dinner parties because there's eight people and
politics comes up.
You loosely Joe Rogan.
I don't want to hear about it no more.
You lose me.
These new political people talking nonsense.
You lucidly move forward.
Either impeach him,
get a new one or shut the fuck up.
I can't,
you'll put the news on anymore,
but it's definitely 20 minutes on.
Yeah.
He didn't send the check.
He called her,
what the fuck man?
Just tell who gives a fuck.
Who gives a fuck?
There's gotta be something more.
There's got to be a seal stuck on a beat somewhere.
This fucking country,
something more important than this shit every fucking day.
So the politics is over my world.
Religion,
you know,
I don't want it there.
You're not supposed to talk about politics or religion at those fucking things,
but this new breed of gentile,
they just talk for the sense of talking to see who's the smartest person in the
room.
And at the end of the day,
they're all a bunch of dump fucks anyway.
Okay.